now let's go back and analyze that same
problem that we were looking at before
of a wheel rolling down an incline plane
and it's rolling without slipping but
instead of using the energy method we're
now going to use the torque method so
let's consider the center of mass and
what we want to do is draw the forces we
have a normal force we have gravity and
we have the friction force about the
center of mass our wheel has a radius R
let's choose a coordinate system I had J
hat and so we have a right-handed system
K hat and that will correspond to some
angle theta now here we're now going to
enlarge how we apply both translation
and rotation and the beauty of this
problem is we've now can decompose our
motion into translational motion and
rotational motion so for the
translational motion we'll apply
Newton's second law now if this is the
angle fee then that's the angle fee as
well and so our forces in the I hat
direction
we have mg sine fee minus the friction
force and that's equal to the X
component of the acceleration now we
also can choose the center of mass to
calculate the torque and so what we're
really just studying here is simply our
old problem in the center of mass frame
of fixed axis rotation and you can see
gravity is acting at the center of mass
so it produces no torque about the
center of mass the dermal force is
directed towards the center of mass and
so when we take that vector product of
our cross n from cm to this point down
here the contact point these forces are
anti-parallel so the normal force
produces no torque and the only torque
that we have is from the friction for
and that friction torque is going to
give us a positive angular acceleration
in the K hat direction it's at right
angles with the vector R so we have FS
times R equals I center of mass times
alpha and these are our two dynamic
equations but remember when the object
is rolling without slipping let's just
remind ourselves that VC m equals R
Omega and if I differentiate the ACM
which is what we're calling ax is equal
to R alpha so this ax here is the
acceleration of the center of mass and
that's our third condition and so now I
see that I have three equations and my
unknowns FS ax and alpha and so I'm
going to solve these equations for a and
I'll look at these equations and what
I'll do is I'll just substitute for
alpha ax over R and then have solve this
equation for FS and put it in there and
so I get mg sine fee now my FS is equal
to IC M over R times alpha but alpha is
a x over R so that's a X and an R
squared notice dimensionally I is M R
squared so this is just M a the
dimensions of force mg dimensions of
force and that's equal to ma X and now I
can solve for ax and I get mg sine fee
divided by M plus I see M over R squared
now ax is a constant and we can from our
kinematic equations if our object
is moving a distance s as it drops
height H we know from kinematics and we
could work this out we have that the X
cm is one half a cm T squared and we
know that that the velocity VC M equals
a cm times T and so when we put these
two together this is the distance s we
get that the velocity cm is equal to the
square root of two s times a cm now s is
equal to H over sine fie s H over s is
signed fee and so V cm equals the square
root of 2 H sign fee times a cm but
we've solved for a cm mg sine fee over m
plus IC M over R squared and so we get
the square root of 2 mg H over m plus IC
M divided by R squared and this agrees
with our energy method